I Amazon a book for this person I heard
this person likes Amazon so I got I got
this for then he who shall not be named
who submitted this cease and desist
letter to me to try to get me to shut up
I have this book for this this
individual previously on fake guru guys
we have an epidemic of fragile
millionaires I'll tell you the normal
plan for a lot of these fake gurus who
want to evade criticism is to send a
cease and desist letter to me which I
will promptly throw in the trash and
then he can subpoena me and I have
liability insurance and I will continue
talking about I'll talk about you all
day but ultimately it's not about him
having a realistic claim it's about him
silencing criticism and hoping it goes
away and anytime someone wants to hide
the truth it becomes that much more
important to tell do not speak his name
guru today we have an exciting story
guys we have a a hot race for the fake
guru trophy of the year figure of the
year it's very exciting I thought kt9
had it had it sealed but this contains
the Dark Horse's
attempt to take back the throne He Who
Shall Not Be Named in this video say his
name in the comments at your own risk
this envelope contains a cease and
desist letter from He Who Shall Not Be
Named towards the channel it's
confidential according to this legal
team I've carefully reviewed it and I
have a few things to say about the
contents and the type of person who
would send this and then as a show of
good faith
yours truly Sifu is going to show you
guys how to be magnanimous how to be
generous I'm going to offer this person
a gift a gift from me - He Who Shall Not
Be Named okay so starting with the
contents of this guy's I wish I could
tell you
listen it's very explicit the the
cease-and-desist that is confidential
I'm no lawyer I looked it up online it's
it's kind of hard to tell what I can say
what I can't say so I am NOT going to be
revealing the contents the exact
contents of what's going on in here but
I'll tell you what's very clearly
obvious and doesn't reveal anything
about the thing it has to do with things
I've said about He Who Shall Not Be
Named it's that you know it's just the
defamation cease and desist the problem
is is that it doesn't have any merit
right it's a slap lawsuit slap is an
acronym that stands for strategic
lawsuit against public participation
these are frivolous suits with no legal
merits specifically designed to stifle
public debate or dissent and these
happen all the time a characteristic of
slap suits the whole point is to put the
defendant through a difficult painful
experience and even if cases fail in
lower courts as they often do the
plaintiffs can find ways to extend them
through intensive discovery requests
depositions and appeals that drain the
targets time and resources and
alarmingly journalists are not the only
ones targeted with slap suits in some
cases that can be used to silence
citizen activists it's made to shut me
up
guys and we're not gonna shut up in
America you know again it's not Korea
all these gurus think we live in Korea
[Music]
but guys we haven't broken any laws but
this has all been within free speech
fair criticism fair use consumer
advocacy work I don't have a course to
sell you right this person might go to
say hey if a guy with a course talked
about about me then we have a problem
because maybe he's trying to profit off
of the people that I lose but I'm not
getting people buying a course when they
leave this guy I'm just saving them two
thousand dollars that's all I'm doing so
so the lawsuits ridiculous and for that
reason and because I also promised you
guys I would do it it is going and to
well that was anticlimactic the trash
because it's ridiculous and it's an
attempt to bully me and silence me and
we're not gonna let that happen guys
we're not gonna let that happen on
copies though I told myself two things
when I started this channel I said
number one no one's off off the table no
one's off limits that means that even
when I talk to these gurus a lot of them
have approached me behind closed doors
trying to come up to me I I can't make
friends with these guys I don't say hey
since we're buddies I'm not gonna make a
video budget that's not how this works
if you're a fake guru you get caught out
but number two the second rule of coffee
Zillow is that we don't respond to
intimidation we don't respond to threats
we don't respond to threats against my
financial situation you know I'm not a
I'm not I'm not I'm not rich guys right
I spend most of the money made from this
channel directly back into our liability
insurance to protect us from bullies
right hey so this isn't even this isn't
this isn't for me right it's for you the
people it's why I have people like like
Garrett on the teacher who joined to
hide wrinkle closure in lost $26,000
it's why I have anonymous interviews
with people who lost thirteen thousand
dollars with all manner of scams because
this ultimately is about getting you the
information and we cannot back down to
threats like this so I'm just here to
tell you what's HAP
to update you on what's going on but
we're being legally threatened basically
it's it's it's it's a matter of take
down the videos the posts or else but
we're not going to do it and come hell
or high water you know whatever they
decide to do we will be reporting on it
we will be talking about it
they're not going to silence coffee
Zilla but number two I have a gift for
this person He Who Shall Not Be Named
okay and let me explain the gift before
I talk about it guys as we saw in the
last video I think there's a bit of an
ego problem here right there's a bit of
a feeling when you make a certain amount
of money that I can just throw money at
problems to make them go away I don't
actually have to allow free speech about
me I don't actually have to allow bad
post about me I can just silence
criticism and I think that a certain
type of person does that I think there's
a psychology behind it I think it's some
kind of a syndrome I think there's a
little problem going on here and so to
help that little problem I I Amazon a
book for this person I heard this person
likes Amazon so I got I got this for
them okay so if this person would like
to anonymously contact me he who shall
not be named who submitted this cease
and desist letter to me to try to get me
to shut up I have this book for this
this individual if they would like to
send me their address I can ship it
right to them but let's just open up the
book and see we'll roll real reseal it
later but I want to show you guys the
book that was for this person so they
can see what a great prize they'd get if
they would just just you know stop
trying to silence me all the time look
check it out this is a book that I feel
is appropriate for the type of person
who feels that they need to silence
critics online who are calling out
predatory behavior this is a this is a
book I feel is appropriate for people
who get very testy when you talk about
them for any reason at
you know what I mean look on the back
we've got the almost an inch ruler hmm
well look I don't know about the
specifics you know for the contents but
my guess I hear that he's a leading
authority on helping people you know
with maybe confidence issues maybe maybe
some kind of some kind of a like like
like a psychological syndrome obviously
I'm not a doctor I'm not diagnosing
anybody I don't know if this person has
this situation my guess is that if there
is a situation it it might be a small
situation
you know worth worth getting addressed
I hear meditation is good hold on let's
lo look at that they even have a little
they even have little illustration
obviously this is all a joke and I'm not
saying anything about anyone's problems
big or small but but what I am saying is
that you know I do sometimes wonder
about the people who are submitting
cease and desist letters for YouTube
videos right III do wonder about that
and and so if you know if I get an email
address if they'd like to go ahead and
put that I can go ahead and send that to
you I'm really thinking that it might be
a book that is applicable to a lot of
these gurus selling courses I think it'd
be valuable you know they all read
expert secrets by Russell Brunson but
have you heard of aunt Smith
have you heard have you heard of an
Smith things to think about things to
think about obviously I don't want to
lawsuit nobody wants a lawsuit but I
refuse to be silenced I refuse to have
not just for me but I refuse to have the
voices of the victimized and the preyed
upon be silenced as well I refuse to let
it happen guys
until next time love you guys I love the
support of the coffee Zillah fake guru
army have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
but never shoulda tried
[Music]